aujourd'hui
[Musique]
Alexis Samson rencontre sa travailleuse
sociale à l'hôpital Notre-Dame après
chaque séance il reçoit une carte
prépayée pour des repas à la cafétéria
de l'établissement
l'hôpital offre désormais une aide
alimentaire à plus de 800 personnes en
situation d'itinérance avec des
problèmes de consommation ou encore à
des familles immigrantes c'est une façon
de créer des liens avec des personnes
qui refusent parfois de recevoir des
soins de santé ou d'aller dans une
banque alimentaire
[Musique]
va avoir du
vracy au poulet des plats pour emporter
des sanwichs des salades l'offre et
variées si ils passent inaperçu c'est
dans le fond ils viennent quand ils
veulent ils prennent ce qu'ils veulent
ils passent à la caisse dans un contexte
où les Banques Alimentaires peine à
répondre aux besoins ce genre
d'initiative pourrait facilement
s'implanter ailleurs croient le PDG de
la mission bon accueil à Montréal de
plus en plus selon moi c'est mon opinion
va falloir avoir des partenariats avec
des organismes ou des instances avec un
capacité institutionnel pour vraiment
répondre à un problème qui est
préoccupant préoccupant car la demande
d'aide alimentaire ne cesse d'augmenter
au Canada en 2022 le recours aux banques
alimentaires étaient en hausse de 15%
par rapport à 2021 et de 35% par rapport
à 2019 on a beaucoup de difficultés à
faire face à un niveau de demande comme
ça traditionnellement le réseau des
Banques Alimentaires on
réussissait à faire face à la demande
grâce à nos donateurs l'initiative de
l'Hôpital Notre-Dame a été simple à
mettre en place et d'autres hôpitaux
comme l'hôpital de Verdun pourrait
bientôt emboîter le pas ici
Marie-Isabelle Rochon Radio-Canada
Montréal